I want to look at two sets of issues.
I want to in a way conclude,
uh,
my interpretation,
my reading of the second treatise by focusing on the role of executive power in
Locke's theory of government,
Locke's theory of constant of the constitutional state.
What did particularly focusing on the role of the executive visa vi the
legislative branch of government.
And then I want you to turn a little more speculative speculatively to thinking
about lock,
uh,
and the American regime and the current state of political philosophy,
modern contemporary American political philosophy.
But let me start first by going back and sticking with the second treatise by
talking a little bit about the role of legislative and executive power.
The last time I think,
uh,
I was concluding by arguing that lock doesn't endorse a necessarily one
particular form of government,
uh,
from any other.
He is an advocate of what we have come to call limited government of,
of constitutional government.
There is that important passage where he ridicules the Hobbs' sovereign is a
lion a and tells,
uh,
we,
we did not enter into the social compact to be devoured by lions.
He says,
the,
the form of government must be limited,
although he's relatively open or at least noncommittal agnostic,
you might say,
as to what particular form,
uh,
that,
that government may take.
One feature of this form of government that he thinks is very important is that
it must in some sense,
embodying a separation of powers.
Powers must be made to check,
uh,
one another,
what he calls in the book,
uh,
the subordination of powers.
This is locks doctrine and you will see it there.
We often associated with mom to secure or sometimes with the federalist authors,
but in fact lock himself,
uh,
is a strong advocate of what he calls the subordination or separation of powers.
Uh,
not exactly the same as we will see between our understanding of executive
legislature should legislative and judicial,
but nevertheless a separation nonetheless.
Uh,
however,
in the first instance a lock emphasizes and in fact,
he continually affirms,
uh,
nevertheless the primacy of legislative authority in England,
in the England of his time.
And even today,
that means a doctrine of what,
what is called parliamentary supremacy.
But he says that the first and fundamental positive law of all constitutions is
in establishing that of the legislative power.
Uh,
the first act after the completion of this social contract,
he says,
is establishing the legislative power.
It is the law making authority of government that is supreme.
Uh,
he wishes to emphasize this seems to push lock,
you might say more in the small d democratic direction.
It is not so much executive power,
the power of a prince,
uh,
but rather the legislature,
the parliament that is a supreme,
there is nothing more important in Locke's theory of constitutional government
in the existence of what he continually refers to as settled or known laws,
settled laws that serve against a arbitrary rule.
In many ways,
the purpose of government for Locke is much less to offset the dangers of
returning to an anarchic state of nature is it was for Hobbs then to prevent the
possibility of the emergence of tyrannical despotic power to radical or despotic
sovereign.
And of course,
locks.
Writing is very much bound up with the big and major constitutional crisis of
his,
of his time leading,
leading,
leading to the overthrow and expulsion of the King James the second.
Yet in many ways,
even though lock is the great advocate of legislative supremacy,
he obviously cannot and does not wish to dispense all together with the role of
executive power.
He often treats the executive,
whether that be in the form of a prince of monarch,
uh,
or even perhaps even a body and uh,
a cabinet of,
of office chief officers as it were.
He treats them often simply as if they were an agent of the legislative or of
the legislature.
The purpose of the executive he sometimes seems to write is merely that of
carrying out the will of the legislature in locks language.
The executive power is ministerial and subordinate to the legislature.
Section one 53,
I believe the executive,
again,
on some aspects of locks writing seems to be little more than a cipher,
uh,
in comparison to the doctrine of legislative supremacy.
And yet lock here is not all together consistent.
One has to say because he understands in every community,
okay,
there is a need for a distinctive of government dealing with matters of war and
peace.
Lock calls this the federative power.
Every community he says like Hobbs is to every other community what every
individual is to every other individual in a state of nature and a distinctive
federative or war,
making power within the government is necessary for dealing with matters of
international conflict,
conflict between states and in a remarkable passage lock notes that this power
he says cannot be bound by antecedent,
standing positive laws,
but it must be left to quote the prudence and wisdom of those whose hands it is
in to be managed for the public good.
In other words,
lock seems to suggest that this particular kind of this branch of government,
uh,
this federative branch,
which falls to some degree under the executive,
must have a certain latitude even apart from the law that realize he says on the
prudence and wisdom of those whose hands it is,
it is in to manage it for the public good.
In other words,
matters of war and peace cannot be left to the legislature or to standing laws
as he calls them alone,
but requires the intervention of strong leaders.
What he calls in an absolutely stunning passage.
God did like princes section.
If you don't believe me,
section one 66 locks reference here to God.
Like princess seems to recall Machiavelli in many ways.
Machiavelli's talk of armed profits.
Uh,
it is necessary in extreme situations for such princes to call on their
prerogative power.
It isn't,
it is impossible lock rights to foresee and so by laws to provide for all the
accidents and necessities that might make concern the public and that during,
in other words,
contingencies or emergency situations,
the executive must be empowered with this prerogative power to act for the good
of the community.
For this reason,
it seems the executive is not simply a tool or an agent of the legislature,
but he says again,
must have the power to act according to discretion.
That is to say according to his own discretion,
for the public good,
without the prescription of law.
Those are locks own words,
how to balance this.
His argument for constitutional government and legislative supremacy with this
doctrine of prerogative power and what seems to be a kind of a power of God,
what he calls in no uncertain terms,
the godlike princes and their need to exercise this power locks prerogative is
in many ways the result of simply the inability of law to foresee all possible
circumstances,
all possible contingencies.
That's an argument that goes as far back as Aristotle.
We've seen our inability to make rules that can apply to all possible events,
makes it necessary to leave some discretionary power in the hands of the
executive to act for the public safety locks.
One,
one of the examples that lock gives of the use of this power is in fact a
domestic,
not a,
uh,
an international issue,
which is to say in the case of a fire,
uh,
in a,
in a city,
it is sometimes necessary for the,
as he says in his day for the fire department to tear down the house of an
innocent person,
uh,
to prevent the fire from spreading to other houses.
This is,
this is acting for the public good of the community.
Even while in some ways it's clearly a violation of rights of property and so
on.
He understands this is as a piece of prerogative power acting for the public
good.
In fact,
the example is not so far fetched.
Think today for example,
about arguments we have today even in Connecticut.
Uh,
there's a big argument going on about the,
the right of what's called eminent domain,
uh,
the right of the government to uh,
to uh,
absorb or to take over private properties.
Uh,
whenever it w w you usually for things like schools or airports but also for
general improvement when it is thought it will enhance the public good.
There's a big debate going on that now out in new London and in Brooklyn also
with the argument about the creation of some civic centers,
some sports arena that will require the demolition of certain neighborhood
houses.
And there's a big debate about this eminent domain.
What is that?
But in a way locks the example of prerogative power acting,
doing something that is somehow said to be for the public good.
That,
but that represents some kind of extra constitutional powered.
But the question for lock is for any constitutional lawyer is what are the
limits of this prerogative power?
What check,
uh,
if any,
is there on this power to prevent their,
uh,
abuse?
Well,
lock doesn't exactly say yes.
Uh,
yes,
right.
He doesn't exactly say he raises this question to be sure of fundamental
importance for a constitutional government.
Does executive authority,
he asks us,
extend to all things even or especially in times of war.
Think about the debates that are going on now about a detainees at Guantanamo
or,
uh,
the issues of domestic spying when it comes to issues of,
of the,
the war on terror.
Are these examples of prerogative power.
That is to say the executive acting outside the limits or the bounds of
constitutional authority for the sake of protecting the public good.
Or are these,
uh,
examples of,
of kind of political absolutism is the invocation of this power in some ways
going down the slippery slope to despotism and absolutism.
I will leave it to you or your sections to try to discuss these matters,
but lock himself praises those who he caused the wisest and best princes of
England as being those who have exercised the largest prerogative,
uh,
on behalf of the public good.
This,
this is beginning to sound more and more in some respects like Machiavelli,
then the advocate of,
of again,
limit limited government.
Some this,
this power comes into play.
He says,
especially during times of national crisis or emergency,
uh,
when it is necessary to act,
for the public safety.
Uh,
in some ways,
and again,
this seems to have special resonance for us today as we face issues like states
of emergency states of exception.
There are in fact political theorists,
uh,
one name comes to mind,
a 20th century German,
a legal philosopher by the name of Carl Schmitt,
uh,
who argued that the state of emergency or the exceptional,
situation,
uh,
is the essence of politics,
and that the person or body who has the power to declare the exception is none
other than the sovereign.
So from Schmidt's point of view,
you might say,
ah,
this isn't this idea of prerogative as a kind of extra constitutional power that
the statesman must of necessity utilize when ordinary constitutional operations
like the rule of law,
uh,
prove to be inadequate.
But consider another example,
if you like that prerogative power about prerogative powers may be granted by
the constitution.
Consider Lincoln's famous suspension of Habeas Corpus during,
during the civil war.
Lincoln interestingly did not take this extraordinary step by appealing to an
extra constitutional power that obtains in times of crisis.
Rather Lincoln argued quite forcefully that this sort of prerogative power is
already deeply embedded within the structure of constitutional government.
He cites the constitution when it,
when it came to the,
to the suspension of Habeas Corpus.
The constitution rights,
the privilege of the writ of Habeas Corpus shall not be suspended unless when
it,
when in cases of rebellion or invasion,
the public safety requires it.
In other words,
the constitution itself seems to allow for this extraordinary kind of action,
at least in cases of rebellion or invasion.
When he says,
when it says the public safety requires it,
the constitution seems to embody within itself our constitution,
that is this Lockian power of prerogative that comes into effect or can be
legitimately exercised in times of rebellion or invasion.
Are we living in that kind of age now?
Not rebellion perhaps,
but invasion.
Well think,
think about that again.
Uh,
are these arguments applicable to uh,
our,
our situation today in some sense when it comes to debates about the extent of
executive power to embark on these extraordinary measures
and yet at the same time lock is aware clearly of the abuse of these kinds of,
or the potential abuse of this kind of prerogative.
He asks who will judge,
who can judge whether the discretion of the executive is being used for the
public safety or the public good,
or whether it is simply a kind of usurpation of power,
uh,
in these moments of high constitutional crisis between conflicting powers of
government.
In such cases,
Locke says there shall be no judge on earth.
He says,
the people have no other remedy in this,
but to appeal to heaven,
this is intersection one 68.
How much is contained in that term appeal to heaven?
What does lock main in terms of high constitutional crisis,
when he says there is no judge on earth,
the people must appeal to heaven.
Does that mean they should fall down on their knees and and begin to pray,
uh,
what they should do?
Uh,
unlikely.
by an appeal to heaven lock means the people's right to dissolve their
government.
He raises this question at the very end of the book when a conflict between the
people or their representatives and the executive becomes so great,
uh,
that the very conditions of social trust have been dissolved,
who will be judged and he answers emphatically the people,
uh,
will be judged.
Lock affirms here,
uh,
right of revolution and appeal to heaven or what he calls an appeal to heaven
really refers to an appeal to arms,
to rebellion and the need to create a new social covenant
lock.
You can see is attempting to hold together a belief in the sanctity of law and
the necessity for prerogative that may sometimes have to circumvent the rules of
law.
Are these two doctrines incompatible?
Uh,
I think in many respects,
or at least in some respects,
they are,
uh,
can the prerogative power of the executive be in a way constitutionalized so
that it does not threaten the liberty of its own citizens lock alerts us to this
timeless as well as this very timely problem.
Uh,
one of the best sources for thinking about many of these constitutional issues
today,
uh,
regarding privacy rights and other kinds of citizen rights,
can be found in,
oh,
I would say the last five chapters or so of Locke's second treatise,
I can't think of a better source.
So when the end,
the locks appeal to heaven or Locke says that the people have an appeal to
heaven,
that is to say an appeal to arms and appeal to revolution suggests that at the
end of the day,
lock was a revolutionary.
But I would say also a sort of cautious and moderate one,
if this is not a complete contradiction in terms
I won't
go through chapter 19.
Famous chapter on Revolution in fall,
uh,
to talk about the conditions under which he,
he believed that people have,
can rightfully appeal to heaven as it were,
but locks,
doctrine of consent and legislative supremacy.
This should make him in many ways a hero to Democrats,
to radical Democrats.
His beliefs about limited government,
the rights of property should make him a hero too in some ways.
Constitutional Conservatives and even libertarians.
And the end,
I think Locke was neither or both.
Uh,
like all of the great thinkers in some ways he defines,
he defies,
excuse me,
simple a classification,
but there is no doubt that lock and gave the modern constitutional state.
It's definitive form of expression and the problems of our state,
the problems,
the legal,
the constitutional and political problems that we experience are very much
problems rooted in the philosophy of John Locke and are unthinkable without the
influence of lock.
So that takes me to a theme that I want to talk about for a little while,
which is locks America,
John Locke's America,
no one who,
who reads lock even superficially.
And I would not accuse anyone here of being a superficial reader after all,
but no one can be fail to be impressed,
uh,
of the,
harmony in many ways between Locke's writings and those of the American republic
that he helped to found his conception of natural law rights,
government by consent,
the right to revolution and all are,
are part of the cornerstone of our founding documents.
Just some degree,
uh,
as I've just been suggesting,
a judgment on America is very much a judgment on the philosophy of Locke and,
and,
and vice versa.
Uh,
in many ways to the IX or if anyone is,
I think Locke has the title to be considered America's philosopher king.
So shot.
So how should we think of lock,
uh,
after more or less three centuries of consistent Locky and rule?
Uh,
how should we think of Loc
for many years?
And for many people,
uh,
even today,
the affinity,
the affiliation between lock in America has been regarded in a largely,
although not wholly and largely positive light for many historians and political
theorists or stability or system of limited government.
Our market economy has been the result of a sort of broad consensus over Locky
and principles
over locking in first principles.
But for many other readers of the,
of American history,
this relationship has been seen as more problematic in the 1950s,
uh,
a book written by a famous,
political theorist and historian named Louis Hartz,
a book called the liberal tradition in America complained of Americas,
what he called irrational Lockey aneurysm that was hearts is line that was hard
to just quote,
are irrational Locky and his and by which he meant a kind of closed commitment,
uh,
to locking and principles and ideals that shut off all other political
alternatives and possibilities.
Hearts was someone very much interested in the question,
as is many political theorists have been since,
ah,
why has there been no socialism in America?
Why did America not evolve or develop along European lines with social
democratic parties?
And Socialist parties like the English Labor Party and other,
other kinds of labor movements and,
and hearts.
His argument was that we were sort of arrested in this Locky and phase of
development,
what he called are irrational Lockey aneurysm that closed off,
uh,
in many ways other,
other principals and for still other thinkers,
uh,
more or less on the left,
lock,
legitimized what was called a kind of theory of,
or an ethic of what was called possessive individualism,
particularly locks focused on property and the rights of private property that
makes,
uh,
that focuses entirely,
on market relations or puts the market values ahead of all other things and for
still others.
Uh,
in many ways more recently thinkers have a more assertive communitarian
direction or bent,
uh,
locks,
emphasis upon rights and the protection that government should protect natural,
uh,
or certain unalienable rights suggests a purely or,
or overly legalistic conception of politics that has no language for talking
about the common good,
the public good or other sort of collective goods or benefits.
So my point is that locks influence has not been all together,
uh,
accepted by everyone.
There is,
there has been much ground for criticism of this offense,
this peculiar affinity between Locky and Islam in America.
But today I would say that Locke's theory of liberalism or Locke's theory of
limited,
limited government constitutional government is confronted by another
alternative that in many ways has deep roots in the very tradition which lock
himself,
uh,
the very liberal tradition in many ways with which lock himself is the founder.
And I am referring in particular to a book that many of you will read at some
point in your Yale experience.
Uh,
a book,
a widely read and widely acclaimed book by uh,
a recently deceased,
a political philosopher by the name of John Rawls,
who wrote a book in 1973 called a theory of justice
in many ways,
Rawls.
His book was an attempt to update,
uh,
the liberal theory of the state.
He invokes the idea of a state of nature in original condition is he calls it a
theory of rights,
although he does so in many ways through the techniques of contemporary
philosophy and end game theory.
And Ross's book is probably the most single,
most important contribution to Anglo American political philosophy in the last
generation.
It is a book that situates itself within the liberal tradition,
beginning with Loc,
developed by people like Emmanuel Kant and John Stuart Mill,
and which Raul's himself hope too,
in many ways,
bring to completion,
uh,
in his book a theory of Justice as he calls it stands or falls on its theory of
rights from which all else is derived.
And what I want to do for a few minutes is to contrast,
uh,
Roz's general theory,
so powerful and influential today from that of John Locke's the original founder
of the liberal theory of the state and see how this,
how they have diverged.
Consider the following propositions,
if you will.
Here is John Locke.
Section 27 of the second treatise.
Every man has property in his own person.
This nobody has any right to but himself.
And where there is property,
he writes,
there can be justice and injustice.
Okay,
here is John Rawls.
Uh,
one of the opening pages of this theory of justice.
Each person Rawls rights possesses an inviolability founded unjustice that even
the welfare of society as a whole cannot override for this reason.
He continues justice,
denies that the loss of freedom for some is made right by a greater good shared
to others.
Okay,
so far so good.
In other words,
both of them present their theories of justice,
uh,
as justified in terms of the liberal principles of equality,
freedom and the sanctity of the individual and individual rights both regard the
purpose of government in many ways is securing the conditions of justice is
deriving from the consent or the informed consent of the governed,
but both,
it seems to me go onto differ profoundly about the source of rights and
therefore the role that government has in securing the conditions of justice.
Let me explain a little bit more what I mean
for Loc.
Going back to chapter five of the second treatise rights derive from a theory of
self ownership.
According to his view,
you will remember right,
everybody has a property in his or her own person.
That is to say no one has a claim on our bodies other than ourselves.
It is on the rock of self ownership fact that we have property in ourselves.
It just when the rock of self ownership,
that lock builds his edifice of natural rights,
justice in limited government.
To put it in a slightly different way,
perhaps a person has an identity,
what we might call today a moral what we,
we have moral personality or an identity by the fact that we alone are
responsible for making ourselves.
He uses this metaphor of the work of the body and the Labor of our hands,
but we are literally the products of our own making.
We create ourselves through our activity and our most characteristic activity is
our work locks.
Fundamental doctrine is that the world is the product of our own free
creativity,
not nature but the self.
The individual is the source of all value for lock.
It is this self,
the I the me,
the ego.
That is the unique source of rights and the task of government is to con is to
secure the conditions of our property in the broadest sense of the term,
namely everything that is proper to us.
Now using that as a sort of shorthand.
Uh,
contrast this to Rose's idea.
Rawls adds to his idea of justice.
Something that he calls the difference principle,
the deep he is it sometimes referred to in the literature on,
on Rawls.
What is the difference principle,
this principle maintains that are natural endowments,
our talents,
our abilities,
our family backgrounds,
our history,
our unique history is our place,
so to speak,
in the social hierarchy.
All of these things are from a moral point of view,
something completely arbitrary.
None of these are ours in any strong sense of the term.
They do not belong to us,
but are the result of a more or less kind of random or arbitrary genetic lottery
or social lottery of which I,
or you happen to be the unique beneficiaries.
The result of this,
in other words,
is that no longer can I be regarded,
is the sole proprietor of my assets are the unique recipient of the advantages
or disadvantages I may accrue from them.
Fortune,
luck,
Machiavellian Fortuna,
and that way is utterly arbitrary.
Uh,
and therefore Rawls concludes,
I should not be regarded as the possessor,
but merely the recipient of what talents,
capacities,
and abilities that I may again,
purely arbitrarily happen to possess.
So what does that mean in terms of social policy or theory of government?
The result of Rawls is difference principle and its fundamental difference with
that of John Locke could not be more striking from this point of view.
Okay.
The locking in theory of Justice broadly speaking,
supports a meritocracy,
uh,
sometimes referred to as a quality is equality of opportunity.
That is what a person does with his or her natural assets belongs exclusively to
them.
The right to rise or fall,
uh,
belongs exclusively to them.
No one has the moral right to interfere with the products of our labor,
the products of which,
which may also include not just in a primitive sense what we do with our hands
and bodies,
but what we do with our endowment,
with our intelligence and our natural endowments.
Okay.
For Rawls,
again,
on the other hand,
our endowments are never really our own to begin with.
Um,
they are part of a common or collective possession to be shared by society as a
whole.
The capacities of hard work,
ambition,
uh,
and intelligence and just good luck that,
for example,
got you to a place like Yale,
uh,
for an Ross as a con do not really belong to you or at least the fruits of those
ambitions and intelligence and good luck do not belong to you.
They are,
again,
they are somewhat arbitrary is a result of upbringing and genetics.
They're not,
they're not yours or mine in any strong sense of the term,
but rather a collective possession that can be or should be distributed.
The fruits of which distributed to society as a whole consider the following
passage from Rawls.
The difference principle he writes represents in effect in agreement to regard
the distribution of natural talents as a common asset and to share in the
benefits of this distribution,
whatever,
whatever it turns out to be,
whatever it turns out to be.
Your intelligence or your drive or your endowments are,
or again,
what he calls a collective asset.
Think about that.
And it is this conception of common assets that underwrites Rawls is theory of
distributive justice and the welfare state just as Locke's theory of self
ownership justifies his conception of limited government and the constitutional
state.
According to Raul's.
Again,
justice requires that social arrangements be structured for the benefits of the
least advantaged in the genetic lottery of society.
His thought experiment that he caused the original condition specifies that
nobody would know in advance in this condition what their particular endowment
intellectually in many other ways would be.
Therefore,
every individual would,
uh,
in contracting,
with the whole would agree to share equally in the benefits of this,
uh,
as it were genetic lottery.
So redistributing our common assets does not violate on Rawls as account the
sanctity of the individual because again,
the fruits of our labor,
we're never really ours to begin with.
Uh,
unlike lock,
uh,
whose theory of self ownership provides a moral justification for the
individual,
for the self,
for our moral personality.
Rawls is different.
Principle maintains that we never again belong to ourselves at all.
We never really have ownership in ourselves,
but are always part of a larger social.
We,
uh,
s a social collective,
a collective consciousness whose common assets can be redistributed for the
benefit of the whole
lock and Rawls.
The point I'm trying to make is they represent two radically different visions
of the liberal state.
Uh,
one broadly libertarian,
the other broadly welfare wrist,
uh,
one emphasizing liberty,
the other emphasizing,
uh,
equality.
Uh,
interestingly again,
this represent this transition.
This evolution represents a change which has gone on within,
uh,
in many ways the liberal tradition itself.
Unlike some of these other critics,
Rawls does not come to be claiming from a tradition outside of liberalism,
but to be developing certain arguments from within,
uh,
the liberal tradition and yet has moved in a wave,
clearly very different from its Locky and formulation.
Both of these views,
again,
they begin from common premises but move in very different directions.
Locke's theory of self ownership regardless of the political community in
largely negative terms as protecting our ad antecedent individual selves or an
individual rights Rovs us theory of common assets regarding the community.
In a far more positive sense is taking an active role in reshaping and
redistributing the product of our individual endeavors for the common interests.
The question for you,
it just like the question for any of us,
uh,
is which of these two views is more valid or which of the two strikes you is
more powerful or plausible?
My own view,
and I love to editorialize,
but my own view is far closer to American theory to Locke's theory,
which I think,
uh,
then then Rawls.
Okay.
The declaration of independence,
the Charter of American Liberty States that each individual is endowed with
unalienable rights among which are life,
liberty,
the pursuit of happiness.
The very indeterminacy of the last phrase,
the pursuit of happiness with its emphasis upon the individual's right to
determine happiness for themselves suggests a form of government that allows for
ample diversity for our natural talents and abilities.
And all the declaration,
uh,
certainly intends that the establishment of justice,
is one of the first tasks of government.
Nowhere does it imply that this requires the wholesale redistribution of our
individual goods and assets.
And second,
although Rawls is clearly attractive,
uh,
excuse me,
Roz's clearly attentive to the moral ills of inequality and we will turn to that
problem in phatic ugly.
Uh,
on Wednesday when we look at John Jack Russo's essay on inequality,
there has never been a more powerful,
passionate and persuasive critic of the ills of inequality than John Jacques
Rousseau.
Uh,
but while Rawls is certainly attentive to the moral ills of inequality,
he seems very naive about the mechanisms,
the actual political mechanisms by which inequalities will be rectified.
Rawls wants government to work for the benefit of the least advantaged,
but this will require the extensive and often arbitrary use of judicial power,
uh,
to determine who has a right to watch,
far in excess of the powers of the court.
The result would be,
I think if we follow Rawls,
his teachings,
uh,
to their letter,
the result would be not a class of philosopher kings,
but rather a class of chief justices,
uh,
endowed with the power to rearrange and redistribute our collective assets for
the sake of the maximum degree of social equality.
It is no surprise that the warmest reception that Rawls is the writing gets
today is in the schools of law,
is in the law schools where he has had an enormous influence on shaping the
education of the current and the next generation of lawyers,
judges and possibly chief justices who may be looking to,
uh,
again,
looking not to the constitution,
but to Rose's theory of justice as a,
uh,
as a,
again at a litmus or a tool for bringing about a social redistribution.
So I leave you on that sobering note,
but a return to lock such as it is,
uh,
even if such a return where possible is by no means a panacea to what ails us.
I am not suggesting for a moment that lock is some kind of cure all.
Some historians,
let me just just mention again,
Louey hearts was but the most famous treat America as a nation uniquely built
upon locking in foundations America,
he believed remains something of a lackey and remnant,
a Lockey in,
yeah,
our remnant fossil in some ways in a world increasingly governed by more radical
forms of modernity.
In fact,
it has been our sort of stubborn Lockian aneurysm that has a in many ways
prevented the kinds of extreme ideological polarization and conflict that one
sees throughout throughout much of the 19th and 20th centuries,
but locks effort to build a kind of modern republican government on the low but
solid foundations of self interest and self ownership and the desire for
comfortable preservation could not help but generate its own farms of
dissatisfaction.
Can regime dedicated to the pursuit of happiness or to the protection of
property ever satisfy the deepest longings of the human soul kinda regime
devoted to the rational accumulation of property answered those higher order
needs or higher order virtues like honor,
nobility and sacrifice can urge gime devoted to the avoidance of pain,
discomfort and anxiety produce anything more than contemporary farms of
epicureanism and nihilism.
In any case,
I'm suggesting no more than any other land could.
America insulate itself from the great heights as well as the great depths of
later farms of modernity.
America,
as a former teacher of mine,
once said,
is the land where the many facets,
the many faces of modernity are working themselves out.
We are,
but a moment,
a moment in the kind of comprehensive self dissatisfaction that is,
uh,
modernity.
So that a return to Lockey aneurysm in many ways is not so much a cure for the
pathologies of maternity.
I would suggest that those pathologies are themselves already rooted in the
pathologies of lock.
Uh,
I will end on that,
on that sober note,
and encourage you to take Russo's advice about loving one's country.
Uh,
I'm seriously on Tuesday.